hallo Silbermond und zwar habe ich eine
Frage eine sehr gute Freundin von mir
ist ein riesen Fan von euch und ja ich
habe jetzt überlegt so wie kann man es
ja ermöglichen dass ich vielleicht euch
auch mal privat privat jetzt nicht
unbedingt aber vielleicht mal näher
kennenlernen kann oder gibt's da
irgendwie eine Kontaktmöglichkeit wird
mich total
interessieren ansonsten vielleicht
können dem Christof ja auch ein
Autogramm mitgeben für Jenny ich würde
mich freuen alles liebe und ich bin raus
euer Jimmy Ciao ja also zu deiner Frage
ja ich glaube schon dass man uns treffen
kann also wir sind jetzt ja dieses Jahr
wieder viel unterwegs bedeutet wir
spielen auch wieder viele Konzerte und
wir versuchen immer noch nach den
Konzerten rauszukommen und noch ein paar
ja bisschen zu quatschen paar Autogramme
zu schreiben also da ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit auf jeden Fall sehr
sehr groß dass ihr uns treffen könnt so
viel kann ich schon mal sagen ne und es
gibt momentan ja noch eine Aktion wo die
Wahrscheinlichkeit auch sehr groß ist
uns zu treffen wir haben gerade eine
Aktion mit unseren neuen Single ja ja
wenn du die zu Hause hast oder deine
Freundin die zu Hause hat die sollen
Bild mit sich und der Single machen dann
aber es muss ein bisschen abgefahren
sein ja also an Ihrem Lieblingsort oder
sich irgendwas einfallen lassen denn wir
verlosen unter den besten Bildern die
ihr dann auf unser Facebookseite postet
verlosen wir eine Achterbahnfahrt mit
uns ja Achterbahn ist natürlich jetzt
ein bisschen schlecht wenn deine
Freundin nicht gerne Achterbahn fährt
sollte sie es vielleicht nicht machen
aber da kann man auf jeden Fall
vielleicht Siebener Bahn das war der wi
der Witz des Tages Antwort zu Achtung
Füße hoch der Witz kommt
flach genau also so viel dazu das wä
auch noch eine Möglichkeit auf jeden
Fall uns nicht nur bei autogramstunden
zu treffen sondern vielleicht auch bei
einer
Achterbahnfahrt